hello and welcome to the agenda
next week we'll be in strasbourg for the
last plenary before christmas
let's take a look at what's on offer
first up president jean-claude juncker
will present the commission's priorities
for 2015.
last time around the plenary he unveiled
a 315 billion euro investment plan for
europe
citizens businesses have all been
calling for change
for a refocus on jobs and growth but how
can europe begin its rejuvenation over
the coming years
on which programs will money be spent
we'll find out on tuesday
priorities are all well and good but the
eu
has some big bills to pay and that's
been a sticking point for signing off on
next year's budget
once again here we are at the end of the
year and the budget is up in the air
a preliminary deal has now been reached
between eu leaders and the parliament on
a condition
that the commission starts to pay off
unpaid bills totaling 23.5 billion euros
and get debts under control by 2016.
on wednesday it'll be d-day for the
141.2 billion euros
2015 budget find out how the vote goes
at the plenary
could a landmark vote by the european
parliament to recognize the state of
palestine be the catalyst to address the
palestinian question
in a move that angered israel sweden
became the first western european member
state to officially recognize palestine
in october
the uk spain and ireland have all held
symbolic votes with france and possibly
also belgium
set to follow suit will the non-binding
resolution get the support it needs
find out on wednesday how to find the
right balance between the respective
life
and border security meps will debate
migration in the mediterranean
on wednesday also look out for a vote on
the european ombudsman
a vote will take place to elect the
incumbent emily o'reilly on tuesday
but possibly one of the big highlights
of the last session before christmas
will be the unveiling of the winner
of the lux film prize 2014. here at the
parliament and across member states
screenings have been taking place for
all three films which one wins
france's girlhood by celine skiema
polish director
pavel pavlakovsky's eda or how about the
last finalist slovenian class
enemy by rock beach i guess we'll have
to wait to find out
and that's all we have for this agenda
take care and enjoy the week